how are you doing I'm wonderful how are
you I'm good thanks and I'm super
excited to talk to you because you were
Public Enemy Number One for a hot second
there how did that feel I
um V the word villain and enemy and blah
blah blah blah blah I um I I've always
said I don't think it's the right word
to use for me because I I like helping
other people you know I wanted to get
the the dalana shape for my team because
I want to help other people that's what
makes me feel the best um but I do
understand that my personality is hard
to like especially in an environment
like that if you're not one of my
friends then nine times out of 10 you're
not gonna like me or understand why I am
the way that I am and but I was okay
with that I knew I had a Target on my
back but it really didn't bother me that
much yeah and I will say it was great to
see your conversation with Leanne
because we did get to see the fullness
of who you are and I think that was
really important and it made a lot of
sense like the way you playing the game
and how fiercely you were protecting
people and it seemed it was clearly
misconstrued um do you if you had the
chance do you think you would do
anything different um the only thing I
would do different is vouch myself a
little bit harder to become captain
during warships um the way that I
portrayed myself the way that I treated
people this that whatever you know I it
was me um if I got an argument with
somebody it was me if I had to Stand My
Ground it was me you know there's no
changing I've been that way since I was
a kid um but yeah the the warship
situation is the only thing that that
would change that makes sense that makes
sense and um do you think how you grew
up you know I'm going personal space but
I know you shared about your your how
you grew up do you think that had
prepared your like prepared you for the
game what do you um yes because uh I
knew that I had I had to do something
about being there and having this once
in a-lifetime Opportunity um yeah I was
raised by a single mom yeah I was the
first colored person in my family yeah
football got took away from me it it was
just a moment that I finally knew I was
like you're doing something now and if
you just sit there and be quiet and
you're not yourself the whole entire
time you're at the show then what are
you doing it for so I was there to
create a platform for myself um I didn't
have a strategy going in I was like just
be yourself go have fun if people don't
like you people don't like you you're
going to live to see another day it's
okay um so that that's really all it was
but definitely the way I grew up the way
my mom raised me um stand on your own
tin toes you know and just be you nice
nice well I'm sure she's proud and
family and friends are proud of you and
hey if there's an Allstar squid game I
better see you
there yeah you you probably
will and you win it that time it's going
to be great right I
hope yes yes well thank you so much for
taking this little bit of time chat with
me and share your your story I really
appreciate it um I know people are G to
be decided to hear more from you and I
think you're about to blow
up that was so I hope I did a good
enough job with
that